breaking news now from the World Cup and
in the last few minutes both England and
Wales have said they won't be wearing
the one love armbands at their matches
in Qatar we can go live now to our
Sports correspondent Rob Harris who's in
uh Doha so uh Rob bit of a back down
it's been embarrassing for the uh
English and Welsh FAS isn't it
well the English and Welsh FAS have
really hit out at FIFA they asked FIFA
back in September if their players could
wear these one love multi-colored
armbands to draw attention to the
anti-lgbt laws in this country in a very
subtle way and yet they didn't hear back
from them for more than two months only
in the last couple of days did FIFA
respond to them threatening them with
sanctions not just a potential fine but
also sporting sanctions so Harry Kane
and Gareth Bale could have been booked
for breaching the equipment Rules by
wearing these unsanctioned armbands
multi-colored featuring one love and the
statement from the English and Welsh FAS
along with some other European FAS say
they are frustrated by FIFA's decision
and they're calling it unprecedented a
real rupture here between the FAS and
FIFA the leaders of world football just
a few days after the FIFA president
Johnny Infantino on a stage here in Doha
said he felt gay he isn't gay it was
attempted by him to show solidarity but
there really has been a backlash to that
this is a country where same relations
are illegal and it's something that put
off fans from coming to this country
from some groups and it's why the fa
were determined to use their platform
but it seems that ultimately their
attempt to display their principles
collided with FIFA's threats of
jeopardizing their progress at this
tournament because it could have cost
the ability of Harry Kane for England
and Gareth Bale to be on the pitch if
they'd be booked and say then been
booked again so a battle of the armbands
erupted with now what less than three
hours until England begin their World
Cup campaign against Iran Wales in
action against the United States tonight
here in Qatar